joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line is dan orlowski back here on
the show how are you dan
i'm doing great rich good to be with you
but i hope you're welcome good to chat
with you which one are you more
concerned with browns or chargers after
their disappointing week six loss
dan oh no question it's the browns and i
agree with you and and to be honest with
you i'm more concerned as i sit here at
222 on the east coast
on monday than i was six hours ago this
morning after re-watching that tape
um
what was the final score yesterday was
it third did the the cardinals scored 33
or something at 37. if you re-watched
that tape they could have scored 50.
it is so bad on defense for cleveland
right now
and i'm at such a loss for
how that revamped secondary specifically
the safeties are playing so bad the
first play of the game
should be a 70-yard touchdown pass to
christian kirk over john johnson's head
if not for the miles garrett pressure
and this is the third good offense that
cleveland has faced this year they faced
kansas city they faced the charters and
they faced arizona they've had 37 47 and
33 hung on their head and um
that's that's a concern um
yes the injuries are are a reality and
then
the the
fact with baker mayfield um
which i really
if you just watch the tape and you if
you know the type of player he is and
the technician he is
uh that show there's a real thing right
now his he mechanically is so not
representative of who he is um i would
by far and away say the bronze and the
chargers i mean third and three drop by
mike williams a fourth and three drop by
mike wins and justin did not play justin
herbert did not play up to his
kind of standard that he has set um
that's that's an anomaly in my opinion
so yeah i i absolutely hear you on that
what why why do you think this is going
on with baker is it because his left
shoulder as he says feels
crappy you know um what is it the line
he's without two tackles because you
know where
that is one of the most hot button
subjects in the nfl certainly with
brown's fans certainly with many uh fans
who just talk fantasy or or just kind of
surf in or just no baker from his
commercials about him just not being the
caliber of player that he the browns
want him to be or that he can be i'm
wondering what your evaluation is uh of
baker right now yeah there's a lot
attached to it um i'd say number one the
the issue with the shoulders is a very
real thing and again you can tell
that he
baker is and i'm not using this
comparison because you know short
quarterbacks but he is very much so drew
brees he's a technician he's got to be
very mechanically sound and he is that's
what allows him to play one quick and
two have elite ball placement rare ball
placement and when you have the shoulder
that has started to show itself more and
more and if and if i would say
anybody listening think of the last
ridiculous throw baker made her awesome
throw baker made accuracy wise you have
to rack your brain because
it hasn't shown up and last year it was
all over his tape and i think the
shoulders big thing do i think that
there's something going on with the
odell situation i do um
and and again for anybody that you know
disputes that or thinks that i'm trying
to make something up again cut on the
tape i'll tell you right here um
there's a first quarter 512.
first quarter five minutes and 12
seconds he's got to throw debate uh to
odell on third and five in the red zone
just doesn't throw it to him it's a
shallow very next play very next play
they go for it odell is on another
shallow cross now offenses teach things
differently but one of the things you
are taught is versus all-out pressure
and man coverage if you got a shallow
cross unless this team is a notorious
drop people out from the middle of the
field defense like the bangles did to
justin fields a month ago you saw the
shower across big odell's wide open and
he just doesn't look at him and so
this is a continuing thing so i think
the shoulder's a thing i think whatever
is going on with odell beckham and him
that that type of chemistry or
connection that's not there is a very
real thing why isn't it there what what
what's what what could possibly be the
reason that you're kind of either
dancing around or what i mean what is
that dan what are you gonna no i've also
i've always thought two things when
baker has odell beckham on the field he
gets the play call he thinks player
and then he goes to the play as a
quarterback you should always hear the
play call
what's the play then where are my
players
and it's flipped with odell that's
exactly why
the interception last year against the
bengals happens and he ends up tearing
his acl because in the very same game
they run the very same play out of the
very same formation versus the very same
defense and he runs it properly and i
just think there's this thing with okay
where's odell i gotta get a deal the
ball and then i think there's this
aspect where you've seen some parts this
year where he doesn't look at him
even though he should be part of the
progression because it's almost like i'm
trying to prove to everybody that i
don't need him or i don't have to force
feed him to football um
so i think there's there's there's this
aspect of him being inside of his own
head it's definitely and again you can't
run from it anymore this is two years of
tape that says something is there while
he's staring at him too much or he
doesn't look at him at all dan olofsky
from espn here on the rich eisen show
nfl live on at 4 eastern every single
day and so much more that dan does so
um
the best team in the nfc through six
weeks is which
for you what do you take yeah
the cardinals have earned that right um
you know the way that their defense is
playing uh obviously callers playing at
an incredible level um they're like this
power does powerful finesse offense you
know it's so finesse because of their
skill position players that they can
beat you up physically i still say that
there's three teams that at least have
earned the right to be in that
conversation or you know i would bet on
being part of the mix as well tampa
because they're going to get healthy the
dallas cowboys are absolutely real in
the los angeles rams
yeah man i mean the cowboys the reason
why i think they're super bowl
contenders is we finally have seen depth
of of roster we're finally seeing it and
not just depth of roster but separation
of roster they're they're that good and
i know nobody really wants to give
credit to what the cowboys have done
drafting but that kid trayvon diggs is
so special and parsons appears to be
another special kid cedric wilson
pollard taking pressure off of the guys
in front of them on the depth chart i
mean they're deep man they are very dead
on that team yeah rich i i completely
agree and i think a thing too is
so number one you are not going to out
coach them offensively or defensively
you're just not
i mean even
you know even the matlab floors and the
green bay packers or the sean mcvays and
you're not gonna like out you're not
gonna whoop them coaching style in that
game right with kellen moore and dan
quinn that's number one number two
talent-wise they're up there with
anybody i mean they are number three
and this is an adamant part for me their
quarterback has gone to a different
level this year their quarterback was
not the level of playmaker that dak
prescott is right now the only way the
only way you go on the road you're minus
two in in turnovers and you have ten
plus penalties and win is your
quarterback plays brilliant football and
he was brilliant and it's because of the
play making and then the clutch
if we what's not getting talked enough
about today and i tried to talk about it
on get up this morning
fourth and four completion of cedric
wilson on the the drive that they end up
kicking the game tying field goal is a
big time play third and 25 in the nfl
is what do we always hear broadcasters
say well what's the call for certain 25.
you know it's you you're not supposed to
get 24 yards on third and 25. you get 12
14 you feel great the third and 25 by
deck is un it's in it's incredible and
um then obviously the game winning
touchdown is a special play because they
ran that formation nine times uh it's
the only time because they ran that
formation with that action in that game
yesterday
nine times the only time he threw that
ball to cd lamb was on that game-winning
play
so where are they gonna get out coach
then
dan
yeah i think it's fair i think it is
fair to talk about some of the stuff
with mike mccarthy and clock management
i don't think yesterday is the game to
talk about it um
i had a problem with them kicking
zerline on the spot with 2 40 to go new
england's got one timeout and and the
two minute warning left you got them
right where you want them you're on
you're you're right in the middle of the
plus side of the field
i mean you've got all three timeouts
left you feel confident being able to
stop mac jones the way the defense is
playing you go for it man you go for it
you make bill burn that final timeout
you take it down to the two-minute
warning you got yourself a third and
manageable best you can right third and
manageable best you can you could even
pick up the first down on that two
minute warning potential right before
the two minute warning the way that
zeke's running the ball polished running
the ball dial it up and then just take
it right down to the end and you give
zeroline an easier kick right there with
like 30 seconds left in the game i mean
unless you don't unless you think like i
gotta get i don't
i don't know man i had a problem with
that a big time i i don't i don't all
that disagree with you um it's not as no
brainer black and white for me like i
understand and
see where you're coming from in regards
to okay let's go for it because if we
don't make it
um we can get the ball back i believe in
our defense but i would say this they
went for it on fourth and one twice
before in that football game obviously
once in the first drive they get stopped
they go for it again i think in the
second or third drive and they should
get stopped again zeke just makes the
play and i don't know if that had given
them some hesitation of hey because they
didn't run the ball well yesterday you
know it was they were met physically um
by new england and i think you know as
much as we can sit here and say well if
we don't get it then our defense can go
make this stop and they can but that
could be the same thing with the missed
field goal hey let's throw him out there
to see if we can go take this lead and
put pressure on their young quarterback
and guess what if he doesn't make this i
feel just as good about us making those
stops and getting the ball back which
obviously the digs interception is a big
part i it's it's very very gray to me
so i've got three and three teams here
uh i got the steelers i'm gonna throw
the chiefs out here because we all still
believe that i think unless you don't do
you think the chiefs have you hopped off
the chiefs
dan or no no no rich i haven't hopped
off um i think yesterday's game is a
perfect example that winning covers up a
lot of stuff
um
i i feel worse about the game than i did
yesterday after re-watching it i think
if they play a better opponent they lose
um you know the turnovers are what they
are we got to stop running from the
reality that that's just might be who
the chiefs are right now you turn the
ball over like that and the team only
scores seven points that's not normal in
the nfl off those turnovers um you know
with 20 minutes to go in that game
that's a 13 10 ball game 20 minutes to
go and then 15 patrick mahomes
makes six straight incredible third down
conversions not first down third down
conversions i just think that if not for
that star performance cover-up in the
last 15 minutes that game's a different
conversation i'm not off on them no
but i don't feel any better or or have
any less concern about their football
team after yesterday all right so then
let me let me let me uh narrow it down
to this subset uh with you dan orlowski
um we had there were three four one in
three teams that had a chance to dig
themselves out of that hole with a win
in week six once upon a time one and
three they had a chance to win two in a
row and bet but get back to 500 the pats
couldn't do it the eagles couldn't do it
but the steelers and vikings did which
one would you be on steelers or vikings
from three and three with two wins in a
row coming out of it what do you got
minnesota vikings uh that that's an easy
answer for me uh the minnesota vikings
won i think justin jefferson
felin um and kirk cousins with dalvin
cook are very very very difficult to
stop their defense is quietly playing
good solid football this year this is
the mike zimmer defense that we've kind
of known patrick peterson's playing
solid
hunter off the edge has been a absolute
wrecking crew with griffin i i would bet
on minnesota my thing with seattle or my
thing with pittsburgh is if they're not
going to play a backup quarterback every
week um they gave up 20 points to gino
smith and the seahawks offense and they
only scored 23 against right now going
into this week which was historically
bad past events what do you see in big
ben when you look at his tape
yeah i mean there's too many misses
still
and there's not enough big plays
to make up for those misses and so they
are going to be in tight ball games
every week so to speak and they are
going to need him to make
one or two big third down throws the
juju loss is a big deal he missed that
throw last night to claypool um but tj
what bailed him out all right
yeah keep going he's okay he's okay he's
okay
and which team coming off a bite uh this
week are you are you um in on more
saints or 49ers
what do you got for me on that oh
um
you know i i i i'm so con well i'm
interested to see what the 49ers do at
quarterback i would play trey lance um
if you would think that they're awesome
yeah i don't think they're awesome this
year with the injuries you know with
kiddo how long is kittle gonna be out um
with the viret injury in the secondary
orlando i would play trey because i
think every rep trade has shown he's
gotten better you go back to the arizona
game from two weeks ago you know outside
of a couple fourth down stop they beat
arizona and so i'm just injured because
i think he's gonna get better and better
and better um
the saints are so interesting to me
because
they are in a world that they have no
idea what to do with in my opinion
because
while they have the big plays from
jameis this year yeah and they haven't
had that they also have the turnovers
and those have been didn't become a part
of the offense and they you know it's
such when you have built 15 years of
playing ball in a certain way drew never
gave it away and so efficient and you
you didn't beat yourself so and now
you're like well we've got these really
cool big plays
but we're also giving the ball away one
or two more times a game and we're
accustomed to it it's just i think
they're trying to figure out like how to
play football with this style of offense
well i mean what if uh michael thomas
comes back this week he's eligible to
come back i don't know if he will or he
can or what he's going to look like but
if can't guard mike comes back you got
camaro maybe
me i mean that defense too the defense
is better than most in new orleans when
they get cooking too i don't know i i i
i keep an eye on them i i i'd be on
the 49ers though i'm so i'm so hyped
about them i don't know why
but i'm i'm still i'm still not ready to
quit them either yeah yeah i'm really
excited to watch them on sunday night
you know i i think the colts are playing
really good football i think the colts
are snuff a couple snaps away from being
a 4-2 team um their defense is playing
fantastic and so
i'm really for both those games i think
sunday night gives us a very clear
understanding of all right can the colts
really climb back into this are they as
good as i kind of think they are and the
same being said with the 49ers that's a
big game last one for you dan and i know
you got to go you got your meeting i'm
sure or getting ready for your show but
what do you think of my wolverines top
ten you called uh some of their action
this year
kade mcnamara and then you got j.j
mccarthy sitting there you could see
that
jim is kind of itchy to put the kid in a
little bit more
um but mcnamara doesn't really make many
mistakes he's only made one and even
that one against nebraska they were able
to come over come come through uh looks
like you know
you know barring a disappointment
against northwestern they're going to be
undefeated against that meat of the
michigan state penn state ohio state
schedule what do you think yeah i mean
i think michigan is a really good
football team i think their defense is
as solid as a unit that i've seen on
paper i've watched kentucky i've had
cincinnati both those defenses are
really good michigan is very similar to
that they got a lot of talent back there
i'll say this about the offense in the
quarterback position
i think to go in and realistically to go
at michigan state and win to go at penn
state and win and to keep this top 10
kind of thing going
your the keys are going to have to get
handed over because
rich you know this
at the end of the day
one kid can do stuff the other kid can't
and to go beat those two teams on the
road
while you lose some experience and you
lose some valuing of the football and i
don't think mccarthy would be you know
reckless with it i think that you are
going to need some special some special
uncoachable to go beat both of those
games or win both those games if not
either one i think at some point you've
got to go hey young fella go
yeah obviously he's the one who told
alex smith we're going to go with
kaepernick i mean he's done that before
good point and um i don't know you could
just see he's toying with the idea but
mack i think he loves mcnamara i think
he loves him and for a good reason he
doesn't turn it over good he's played
good he's done exactly what they asked
them to do but i don't know if that is
going to be enough on the road versus i
have penn state this week so i'm excited
to see them but i don't i don't know if
on the road it's going to be enough for
those two teams penn state michigan
who's the best team you've seen so far
with your own two eyes than dan yeah the
best team that i've seen so far
cincinnati i think cincinnati's defense
gives them the ability to beat anybody
go beat anybody now would cincinnati
play
really good football over 12 weeks in
the sec i don't know probably not but i
don't need them to in the college
football playoff cincinnati's the best
team i've seen so far kentucky is right
up there with them as well dan orlowski
at danarolovsky7 on twitter at
diorlovsky on instagram um have a good
show today let's do this again soon i
really appreciate it
you're the man boss right back at you
dan orlowski hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here